my dad's like most people when they
think of their father you know was a
wonderful person and
uh um you know we think of him very
fondly
you know he was generous um he was
clever person
you know he'd done some things of real
significance in his life
andy watson's father david received an
obe from prince charles for a lifetime
of work
at the ministry of defence he lived with
alzheimer's for the last 14 years of his
life
it was a slow change you know in the
first instance he knew
what was going on and uh he would write
things down and hide it in his wallet in
order
you know not to be exposed but then
there comes a time as it
matures where he can't do those things
and
he was still a positive generous man
sylvia spate was diagnosed with the
disease
four years ago and it has changed my
life
as far as friendships and things like
that and going out
and going on holiday with friends
i think when you've got dementia
people step back because they're they're
more afraid of it than what you
are until now the focus of alzheimer's
drugs has been to ease symptoms
this is the first to target the actual
cause of the disease
it breaks down the sticky protein that
builds up a plaque in the brains of
people with alzheimer's
it's hoped removing that plaque will
help slow the onset
of the condition that discovery was made
30 years ago
thanks to research by a british charity
it's been underfunded for
so many years and i think we have got a
situation now where we do have
great researchers with great tools doing
great research
there's so much hope like say over 126
drugs that can't be tested and a lot of
them are targeting ammo but they're also
typing other proteins
late stage trials of the drug at
ucanumab were halted in 2019 when
analysis showed it wasn't better at
slowing memory deterioration
more than a hundred potential treatments
for this cruel disease have flopped in
the past decade
it's too late for andy's dad but if this
new drug were approved for use here
at least a hundred thousand people could
benefit
ender brady sky news tv